This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我将在节目中剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代社会中，如何培养坚韧的意志力、好体魄以及韧性。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字“2”加percent，在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方搜索即可。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的有证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transatless. of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理学意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老
listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode, another topic as we break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we are in for such a trait. I'm kind of kidding because this is perhaps not the most exciting topic, but I think it's one of the most valuable during this decade. And that is how we can use psychology, science, even sociology to build self-discipline. The five biggest tips for ensuring that you have all the tools to pursue your goals successfully, whatever domain they're in, whether that's fitness, lifestyle changes, work, creative projects, even just your daily tasks. I think that discipline is such an interesting concept to me, especially in our 20s, because it is seriously the secret ingredient
听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，探讨另一个话题，我们一起来剖析二十多岁的心理学。今天，我们真是大饱眼福。我其实是在开玩笑，因为这可能不是最令人兴奋的话题，但我认为这是这个十年中最有价值的话题之一。那就是我们如何利用心理学、科学甚至社会学来建立自律。确保你拥有成功追求目标所需的所有工具的五个最大秘诀，无论这些目标属于哪个领域，无论是健身、生活方式改变、工作、创意项目，甚至是你的日常任务。我认为自律对我来说是一个非常有趣的概念，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候，因为这绝对是
to achieving anything you want in life. Yet so many of us treat it as optional or believe that it's too hard to achieve. I think that's because of a number of misconceptions that we have about self-discipline. The first one being that if you are disciplined, you need to be aiming for perfection. I think that belief keeps a lot of us from ever even starting something because we truly do buy into this attitude, into this belief that we need to never make mistakes or experience setbacks in order to get to our end goal. This is so far from the truth. Anyone who has done anything cool or interesting or amazing with their life will tell you
实现生活中你想要的一切的秘诀。然而，我们当中有许多人把它当作可选项，或者认为它太难实现。我认为这是因为我们对自律存在许多误解。第一点是，如果你是有自律的，你需要追求完美。我认为这种信念让我们中的许多人甚至不敢开始做一件事，因为我们真心接受了这种态度，这种信念：为了达到最终目标，我们绝不能犯错或经历挫折。这与事实相去甚远。任何在生活中做过很酷、很有趣或了不起的事情的人都会告诉你
that part of the process is learning from the times you almost gave up but kept pushing anyways, the times that you stayed consistent, you implemented your habits day in and day out. Secondly, we tend to believe that self-discipline means sacrifice and giving up all the things that we enjoy for our one major goal. Again, I personally believe that that's incorrect. Sometimes there is a small amount of sacrifice that is necessary, but mainly it just means change. It just means substitution, swapping out one behavior or habit for another one. And instead of viewing that as a sacrifice, which I think creates a lot of negative attitudes towards self-discipline, we should instead be viewing it as an investment
这个过程的一部分，就是从你差点放弃却依然坚持下去的时刻中学习，从你保持一致、日复一日践行习惯的时刻中学习。其次，我们往往认为自律意味着牺牲，为了我们这一个重大目标，放弃我们喜欢的一切。同样，我个人认为这是不对的。有时确实需要做出一点点牺牲，但主要它只意味着改变。它只意味着替代，用一种行为或习惯去换取另一种行为或习惯。我们不应该将其视为牺牲（我认为这会让人对自律产生很多负面态度），而应该将其视为
in yourself that you just weren't previously making. And finally, the negative belief that keeps us from self-discipline is that it's going to be this hard forever. It's always going to be a struggle. I actually think it's the opposite, solely relying on motivation and inspiration, that is a lot more difficult because you're basing your efforts on something that is, let's be honest, quite fickle and not always a constant, you're forcing yourself to do things when you have no incentive in the moment to do them. That is what drains our energy. But self-discipline and consistency is our safety net in those situations. It is the thing that remains constant despite our whims, despite our changing energy levels, despite our mood. And as time goes on, discipline really creates the habits that make any task a lot
你以前没有对自己的投资。最后，让我们对自律望而却步的负面信念是，这种状态会一直这么艰难。它总是会充满挣扎。实际上我认为恰恰相反，仅仅依靠动机和灵感，要困难得多，因为你的努力是建立在某种老实说相当善变且并非总是恒定不变的东西之上的，当你当下没有任何动力去做某事时，你却在强迫自己去做。这才是消耗我们精力的原因。但自律和连贯性是我们应对这些情况的安全网。无论我们的心血来潮、能量水平如何变化、心情如何，它都是那个保持不变的东西。随着时间的推移，自律确实能养成各种习惯，让任何任务都变得更加轻松。
easier to do even when we don't want to do it. Here's the thing. We mostly need self-discipline to do things that honestly we don't really want to do. You know, you don't need self-discipline to binge watch the entire season of Married at First Side. You know, you don't need self-discipline to sleep in till 11 a.m. every day. What we do need it for is to get us into the habits and the routines. We know are going to get us a better outcome. We know they're going to give us a better life than what we currently have, even if they are the harder alternative. I think we often set out to do something to change our life, to change our career, to change our future with a lot of energy and we have a lot of gusto and we are totally sure of the future that we want and we fantasize about the outcome
即使在我们不想做的时候也能轻松完成。事情是这样的。我们主要需要自律来做那些老实说我们并不是真的很想做的事情。你知道，连续刷完一整季的《一见钟情》并不需要自律。你知道，每天睡到上午11点并不需要自律。我们真正需要自律的是让我们进入那些我们知道能带来更好结果的习惯和日常中。我们知道它们会给我们带来比现状更好的生活，即使它们是更艰难的选择。我认为我们经常带着满满的能量和热情去开始做一件事，去改变我们的生活，改变我们的职业，改变我们的未来，我们对想要的未来百分之百确信，并且对结果充满幻想
and we think it's going to be super easy that we'll always have this level of motivation. The thing is though, when we only focus on the end goal and how great that's going to feel, we often don't think about what it's going to take to get us there, all the small daily steps. And self-discipline is that bridge between wanting something and realizing that thing. Staying focused, even when there are a million other things that have your attention. And that's often the case in our 20s. It's also about having the foresight to understand that there will be setbacks, but being consistent, having self-control will allow you.
我们以为这会超级简单，我们会一直拥有这种水平的动力。然而问题是，当我们只关注最终目标以及那种感觉会有多棒时，我们往往不会去想实现它需要付出什么，那些所有微小的日常步骤。而自律就是连接“想要某样东西”与“实现它”之间的桥梁。保持专注，即使有成百万件其他事情在分散你的注意力。在我们二十多岁的时候，这种情况往往经常发生。它还关乎具备长远眼光，明白会有挫折，但保持专注、有自控力将使你能够
you to overcome them. It is one of our most valuable skills. It's very much like a muscle, and it's one that we strengthen over time and with consistency and that we need to train to get the most out of. So lucky for you, there is so much psychology out there in the world, hidden in academic articles, hidden in research. That can really enable us to be more committed to our long-term goals using self-discipline. Rather than just encouraging you to be disciplined and to be more consistent and to be more motivated and to be have strong willpower and just leaving it at that. I want to actually give you five precise practical steps for building this skill in a manner that is actually doable and will inevitably help you realize the dream life that I think we all want.
克服它们。这是我们最宝贵的技能之一。它非常像一块肌肉，需要我们随着时间的推移和不断的坚持来强化它，我们需要训练它以获得最大的收益。所以对你来说幸运的是，世界上有如此多的心理学知识，隐藏在学术文章中，隐藏在研究中。它们确实能利用自律，让我们更能致力于长期的目标。而不是仅仅鼓励你要自律、要更加坚持、要更有动力、要拥有坚强的意志力，然后就此作罢。我想真正为你提供五个精确且实用的步骤，以切实可行的方式培养这项技能，这不可避免地能帮你实现我们所有人内心中都渴望的梦想生活。
So I'm going to cut to the chase because I really don't like when I listen to a podcast that's like five tips to do this, 10 things you need to know about X and they don't give you the list at the very top and then you kind of end up getting a little bit. a little bit lost in the weeds, but in this episode, we're going to talk about these five tips, understanding the psychology behind what motivates you, leveraging our social desirability bias, building micro habits, creating invariable reward by manipulating your own dopamine levels in response to gratification and challenges, shifting from a learned helplessness to a learned industriousness approach, and then finally one bonus tip for those of you who get to the very end.
所以我要直奔主题了，因为我真的很不喜欢听那种说什么“做到这点的五个秘诀”、“关于X你需要知道的十件事”却不在最开头给出列表的播客，那样的话，你最后往往会在琐碎的信息中迷失方向。但在这一期节目中，我们将讨论这五个秘诀：理解激励你的心理学背后的原理，利用我们的社会合意性偏差，建立微习惯，通过在面对满足感和挑战时操纵你自身的神经递质多巴胺水平来创造可变的奖励，从习得性无助转向习得性勤奋的方法，最后，为听到节目最后的你们准备一个额外的小贴士。
That is a very high level list. There's going to be quite a bit of science in this, but it's super digestible. I think, without further ado, let's get into it and start with point number one, understanding what motivates you. You cannot force yourself to do anything if you have no idea why you want to do it. Sometimes we set these very obscure goals. Like, I want to be healthier. I want to be more focused. And the thing is, is that, yeah, those are amazing goals.
这是一个非常高级别的列表。这里面会有相当多的科学知识，但非常容易消化吸收。我想，废话不多说，让我们直接切入正题，从第一点开始：了解是什么在激励着你。如果你完全不知道自己为什么要这样做，你是绝对无法强迫自己去做任何事的。有时我们设定这些非常模糊的目标。比如，我想变得更健康。我想更专注于某事。问题在于，是的，这些都是很棒的目标。
right but they're actually too simple to build self-discipline around because it doesn't contain any of the detail that we need to work with it doesn't get to the why why do you want to be more focused and in what area of your life i see people do this a lot i do this a lot especially with their fitness goals you know they just say something like i want to run a 10k or i want to get fitter those are amazing goals but what's your timeline here why do you want to do that What is motivating you towards this outcome? Self-discipline is created through detail. So how do we get to that core ambition that's at the center of any of our goals? Well, we need to examine behavioral change theory to really understand what motivates us towards
对，但它们其实太简单了，无法围绕它们建立自律，因为它们不包含我们工作所需的任何细节，它们没有触及“为什么”——你为什么要更专注？在生活的哪个领域？我看到很多人这样做，我也经常这样做，尤其是在他们的健身目标上，你知道，他们只是说一些类似“我想跑完10公里”或者“我想变得更健康”的话。这些都是很棒的目标，但你的时间表是什么？你为什么想这么做？是什么在激励你走向这个结果？自律是通过细节创造出来的。那么我们如何触及任何目标核心的那个核心野心呢？我们需要审视行为改变理论，来真正理解是什么在激励我们走向
something. Now, this could be anything, right? It could be a sense of accomplishment. Maybe you like the idea of winning, you like impressing others, you like impressing yourself. maybe you are unhappy with where you are at currently and you want to improve your life. Maybe you just want to be happier. You just want to be healthier. These are all super valid high level reasons. But when you create a goal, I'm going to use that 10K example again and say, I want to run a 10K. You need to include two further details.
某个目标。现在，这可以是任何事情，对吧？它可以是一种成就感。也许你喜欢获胜的感觉，你喜欢给别人留下深刻印象，你喜欢打动你自己。也许你对目前的现状不满意，想要改善生活。也许你只是想变得更快乐。你只是想变得更健康。这些都是超级合理的高层级原因。但当你设定一个目标时——我再次用那个10公里的例子——并说“我想跑10公里”。你需要包含另外两个细节。
Firstly, you need to include a timeline and you need to include a motivator. So I want to run a 10K in six months because I want to show myself that I can do it. Or I want to run a 10K in November this year because doing so will make me fitter and improve how I feel in my body. In those goals, you have those two additional pieces of information that make them actionable. You have a timeline and you have a motivator. And those two additional points will allow you to push yourself and take action regardless of how you're feeling data. day and that is essentially the very definition of self-discipline. The reason why those details work is because they create what we call smart goals. They are specific, they are measurable, you know
首先，你需要包含一个时间表，你还需要包含一个动力来源。所以，我想在六个月内跑完10公里，因为我想向自己证明我能做到。或者我想在今年11月跑完10公里，因为这样做能让我更健康，并改善我身体的感受。在这些目标中，你包含了另外两条使它们可付诸行动的信息。你有一个时间表和一个动力来源。而这两个额外的点将使你能够推动自己并采取行动，无论你当天感觉如何，而这本质上正是自律的定义。这些细节之所以起作用，是因为它们创造了我们所说的SMART原则目标。它们是具体的、可衡量的，你知道
when you've achieved the goal. It's attainable. It serves your overarching mission or ambition, which is maybe to get fit, and there's a time frame. Now something I want you to know is that you are a lot less likely to be successful in building the necessary self-discipline to achieve a goal if your motivation for the goal is external rather than internal. For example, if you're trying to accomplish something because you think it will make other people happy or that you're going to prove them wrong or to avoid some weird threat, like a threat of getting fired, it is going to be a lot less effective than wanting to accomplish something for yourself. That is because internal self-discipline is self-directed, self-imposed, self-managed.
你什么时候实现了目标。它是可达成的。它服务于你的总体使命或野心（也许是变得健康），并且有一个时间框架。现在我想让你知道的一件事是，如果你的目标动机是外在的而不是内在的，那么你在培养实现目标所需的自律方面成功的可能性就会小得多。例如，如果你试图完成某事是因为你认为这会让人开心，或者你要向他们证明他们错了，或者为了避免某种奇怪的威胁，比如被解雇的威胁，这会比你想为自己完成某事的效果要差得多。这是因为内在的自律是自我导向的、自我施加的、自我管理的。
It is not reliant on the possibility of a loss or the fear of external judgment or punishment or any of those things. And what they've found time and time again across multiple studies is that this sense of doing something just for you is a lot more powerful and enjoyable. So if your motivation is centered around the opinions of others, trying to impress someone else to fulfill some social norm or expectation. I think at this point, it's really wise to change that to an internal motivator, an internal reason or find a new goal. Because in three months time, when you've stopped thinking about that person and they're no longer relevant in your life, you still want to be able to stay on track. In your journey to accomplishing anything, to being disciplined,
它不依赖于失败的可能性，也不依赖于对外部判断或惩罚的恐惧或任何这些东西。各项研究一次又一次发现的是，这种仅仅为了自己而做某事的信念要强大得多，也愉快得多。因此，如果你的动机集中在别人的看法上，试图给别人留下深刻印象以迎合某种社会规范或期望。我认为在这一点上，真的很明智的做法是将其转变为内在动力、内在原因，或者寻找一个新的目标。因为三个月后，当你不再去想那个人，他们不再与你的生活相关时，你仍然希望能够保持正轨。在你完成任何事情、变得自律的旅程中，
it's also important to keep coming back to that why. The reason this is effective is because of what we call expectancy theory in psychology. The basic premises of this theory is that you are more likely to achieve your goals when you remember why you set them and why they are important. This is because our motivation is based on how much we value a goal and how much you believe you have the capacity to achieve your goal. When you return regularly to why you're doing this, the what, the why, the motivation, you highlight the value of the goal to yourself and you reiterate that you're capable, that there is a future outcome there that you want to be consistent for. You can do hard things. some ways to kind of aid in that active remembering of your motivator of your why is to create a vision board for the outcome
不断回到那个“为什么”也是很重要的。这种方法之所以有效，是因为心理学上所说的“期望理论”。这个理论的基本前提是，当你记住为什么设定目标以及它们为什么重要时，你更有可能实现目标。这是因为我们的动力取决于我们对目标的重视程度以及你相信自己拥有实现目标的能力的程度。当你定期回归到你为什么要这样做、做什么、为什么、动力是什么时，你就在向自己强调这个目标的价值，并且重申你是具备能力的，那里有一个你希望为之保持一致的未来结果。你能做困难的事。一些帮助你积极记住你的动力、你的“为什么”的方法包括：为结果创建一个愿景板
to consume content on social media through podcasts and books that align with your goal because these things act as cues and reminders as to what you're working towards so it's easier for you to stay disciplined in the pursuit of this sometimes far off objective it's also important I think to tell people about your goal for that additional accountability. Now, this doesn't mean that you're doing it for them or that you're reverting to external motivation, more so that you're leveraging what we call social desirability bias in aid of your goal. This leads me to my next big step or tip for building self-discipline. Enlist social support or even accountability. And this is effective because it leverages something that we know about ourselves as humans, which is that
通过播客和书籍在社交媒体上消费与你的目标相符的内容，因为这些东西起到了提示和提醒的作用，提醒你正在为什么努力，从而使你在追求这个有时遥不可及的目标时更容易保持自律。我认为，把你的目标告诉别人以获得额外的问责，这也是很重要的。现在，这并不意味着你是为他们做的，或者你回退到了外在动机，更多的是你利用了我们所说的社会合意性偏差来辅助你的目标。这引出了我建立自律的下一个重大步骤或秘诀。寻求社会支持甚至是问责。之所以有效，是因为它利用了我们作为人类所了解的一个关于我们自身的特点，那就是
we are very social creatures and we want to make others happy. We want to impress them. We don't want to let them down. When we feel like we will let someone down if we don't show up to a run, or we don't get something done on time, or we cancel on them, or we break a promise, this encourages us to be more disciplined and, you know, true to our word. because sometimes, you know, it's super easy to cancel on yourself. It's super easy to just say like, yeah, I'm not going to do that today. Because you are both the enforcer and the doer. However, when we add in a little sprinkle of social accountability,
我们是高度社会化的生物，我们希望让别人开心。我们想给他们留下深刻印象。我们不想让他们失望。当我们觉得如果不去跑步、没有按时完成工作、放了别人鸽子或违背了诺言就会让某人失望时，这会鼓励我们更加自律，并且（你知道）信守诺言。因为有时候，你知道，放自己的鸽子实在太容易了。说一句“好吧，我今天不做了”实在是太容易了。因为你既是执行者，又是监督者。然而，当我们加入一点点社会问责时，
the weight of not doing something we said we were going to do becomes a lot heavier, meaning that we are more likely to do that thing to avoid additional and secondary feelings of shame or guilt. It's also the case that sometimes we actually just perform better when other people are watching us. This is called the social desirability bias. It's why people will are more likely to behave in a pro-social way when they know that cameras are on them or help someone else out when they can see that other people are going to observe that. Now, this concept of social desirability bias, this was initially used to describe how people like to overstate their, positive traits and understate their negative traits in social and clinical research. But we can now apply it to this like arena of goal setting. We want others to think that we are good people. That is a very
不做我们答应过的事情的心理负担就会变得沉重得多，这意味着我们更有可能去做那件事，以避免产生额外的、次生的羞耻感或内疚感。有时候，当有其他人看着我们时，我们的表现实际上会更好。这被称为社会合意性偏差。这就是为什么人们在知道有摄像头对着他们时，更有可能表现出亲社会行为，或者在看到其他人会观察时帮助别人。现在，社会合意性偏差这个概念，最初是用来描述人们如何在社会和临床研究中夸大自己的积极特质并淡化消极特质的。但我们现在可以将其应用到目标设定这个领域。我们希望别人认为我们是好人。这是一个非常
basic human desire. And we know that attributes like self-discipline or hard work, they're very positively viewed. They make us look like good people. So when we have the chance to show that we possess these traits in front of others, we are much more likely to do so. How do we apply this knowledge in the strengthening of the self-discipline muscle? It's actually really, really simple. You just need to create opportunities for yourself to be accountable to others in the pursuit of your goal. So I'm going to give you some examples here. If you want to be more focused at work, tell a colleague your to-do list and have them check in with you at the end of the day. and confirm what you've done.
基本的人类欲望。我们知道，自律或努力工作等特质，是非常受人赞赏的。它们让我们看起来像好人。因此，当我们有机会在其他人面前展示我们拥有这些特质时，我们更有可能这么做。我们如何将这一知识应用到强化自律这块肌肉中呢？其实非常非常简单。你只需要为自己创造机会，在追求目标的道路上对他人负责。所以我在这里给你们举一些例子。如果你想在工作时更专注，把你的待办事项列表告诉一位同事，让他们在一天结束时向你核对，
If you want to run a 10K, I know I'm using this example quite a bit, but sign up for a run club and make a commitment to be there two days a week running with others. Even better sign up as an admin. Sign up as like an organizer, then you have to be there.
并确认你完成了什么。如果你想跑10公里——我知道我经常用这个例子——但报名参加一个跑步俱乐部，并承诺一周有两天去那里和别人一起跑步。更好的是，报名做管理员。报名当组织者，这样你就必须去。
You want to be more self-disciplined when it comes to a creative project or a side hustle. Find someone else who wants to do the same thing and carve out two evenings, maybe even one, where you guys are committed. committed to getting on Zoom together or catching up in each other's houses and just working.
如果你想在创意项目或副业方面更有自律。找一个也想做同样事情的人，腾出两个晚上，甚至一个晚上，你们承诺好一起加入Zoom，或者去对方家里串门，然后就是一起工作。
It's like having a standing appointment. It increases your level of commitment and discipline to do hard things by doing them alongside other people. Build like a solid work routine, a solid lifestyle routine around other people as well as yourself. It also just makes it a lot more enjoyable. You know, I have an example of how this is working for me. At the the moment I'm trying to really prioritize my physical fitness, I went traveling for two months and I noticed that I lost a bit of steam. I wasn't as fit as before. And so I set myself a new year's resolution to exercise four times a week. You know what? It would have been really easy for me to have just made that promise to myself, not told anyone, and quit after a few weeks. But I leveraged
这就像是一个雷打不动的预约。它通过和他人一起做困难的事情，提高了你承诺和自律的水平。围绕他人以及你自己，建立一个稳固的工作常规、一个稳固的生活方式常规。这也让事情变得有趣得多。我有这样一个例子，看看这对我有什么用。目前我正试图真正优先考虑我的身体健康，我旅行了两个月，我注意到我的动力有点减弱了。我没有以前那么健康了。所以我给自己设定了一个新年决心：每周锻炼四次。你知道吗？如果我只是对自己做出那个承诺，不告诉任何人，几周后就放弃，那真的太容易了。但我利用了
social desirability and social accountability. I told as many friends as I could about it. I created ways to get other people involved to keep me accountable. So every Sunday, I know that I go for a run with my friend Kay and I don't want to let her down by not showing up. On Tuesdays, I go boxing with my friend Emily. I want to show up. I want to keep the promise not just to myself and my larger goal, but the promise to them to do these weekly steps and activities that allow us to also connect. Moving on to our third tip. Let's talk about micro habits. Now, I'm going to keep this one. one rather brief because if you're interested in this topic, we actually did a whole episode on this. It's episode 53, the power of micro habits. If you want to go and listen to that and I don't
社会合意性和社会问责。我把这件事告诉了尽可能多的朋友。我创造了让其他人参与进来的方法来监督我。所以每个星期天，我知道我都会和我的朋友凯去跑步，我不想因为没有露面而让她失望。周二，我和我的朋友艾米丽去打拳击。我想去。我想遵守承诺，不仅是对我自己和我的宏大目标，还要遵守对他们的承诺，完成这些周常步骤和活动，这也让我们得以保持联系。接下来是我们的第三个秘诀。让我们谈谈微习惯。现在，我要把这部分讲得
want to just be repeating myself. But it is honestly such a life changing, amazing strategy. So micro habits, if you haven't yet heard of this term, they are these small, everyday actions or tiny, itty-bitty routines that turn into automatic behaviours through repetition. The best thing about micro-habits is that they're meant to be easy. But as you build them up, they create self-discipline. Some examples of this are going outside at least once a day, reading one page of a book before bed, eating one-serve of vegetables with every meal, walking to work instead of driving.
相对简短，因为如果你对这个话题感兴趣，我们实际上做过一整集关于它的节目。那是第53集，《微习惯的力量》。如果你想去听那一期的话，我不想在这里重复自己。但它真的是一个改变生活、极其惊人的策略。所以微习惯，如果你还没听说过这个词，它们是那些日常的小行动，或是微小的日常常规，通过重复变成自动化的行为。微习惯最好的地方在于，它们生来就是轻松的。但随着你不断积累，它们会创造出自律。这方面的一些例子包括：每天至少出门一次、睡前读一本书的一页、每顿饭吃一份蔬菜、步行去上班而不是开车。
Those things all seem super-duty. doable, right? And that's the point. It's because they're meant to be. They counteract that all or nothing thinking that gets a lot of us stuck when we're starting out. You know, we immediately think that big is best when it comes to getting started. We want to eat healthier so we throw out everything processed in our kitchen. We replace it with foods that we just actually don't eat that we're not used to and we're not giving ourselves time to adapt to a new routine and lifestyle, meaning that we're more likely to fail because we haven't adjusted and it's not sustainable. When we don't have those habits down pat yet, we're just changing too much too soon.
这些事情看起来都超级容易做到，对吧？这就是重点所在。因为它们的本意就是如此。它们抵制了那种非黑即白的思维，正是这种思维让我们在刚开始时陷入困境。你知道，当我们开始行动时，我们立刻会觉得“越大越好”。我们想要更健康，于是扔掉了厨房里所有加工食品。我们换上了我们实际上根本不吃、也不习惯的食物，我们没有给自己时间去适应新的常规和生活方式，这意味着我们更有可能失败，因为我们没有调整好，而且这并不具备可持续性。当我们还没有完全掌握这些习惯时，我们只是在太短的时间内改变了太多东西。
And some people can do that. Some people can go cold turkey or all or nothing. But I actually think that it takes a lot more effort. It puts a lot more strain on your cognitive and physical resources. when you apply micro habits instead, you break down your big goal into super manageable tasks that actually stop you from getting stuck in the procrastination trap of not knowing where to start. It stops you from feeling overwhelmed and it helps you build momentum so that it doesn't, it's not that age-old story where you set some goal, you achieve it and then you go straight
有些人确实能做到这一点。有些人可以一下子彻底戒掉，或者采取全盘接受或全盘放弃的态度。但我实际上认为这需要付出更多的努力。当你应用微习惯而不是那样做时，它会对你的认知和身体资源造成更大的压力，你把你的宏大目标分解成超级可管理的任务，这实际上阻止了你陷入“不知道从哪里开始”的拖延陷阱。它能阻止你感到不知所措，并帮助你建立势头，这样就不会出现那种老掉牙的故事：你设定了一些目标，实现了它们，然后又直接
back to how you were six months before. it actually creates like a lifestyle change that is going to stay with you for a lot longer. Now, I want you to pause for a second and think back to that goal that you are setting. What are three small micro habits you could do throughout your week that would aid in achieving that goal? Make them super specific but also make them easy. Now what reasons do you have to not do those things given that they require so little effort and investment. When you start with those small micro-habits, you train yourself to be more disciplined. Okay, we're going to take a small, short little break for a second, but when we return,
回到了六个月前的状态。它实际上创造了一种将伴随你更久的生活方式改变。现在，我想让你暂停一秒钟，回想一下你正在设定的那个目标。有哪些三个小微习惯你可以在一周内完成，从而有助于实现该目标？让它们超级具体，但也要容易做到。鉴于这些事情只需要这么少的精力和投入，你有什么理由不去做呢？当你从这些小的微习惯开始时，你就是在训练自己变得更加自律。好了，我们要稍微休息一小会儿，但当我们回来时，
we're going to talk about those final two tips I have for you. And of course, our bonus tip, we're going to be right back after this break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
我们将讨论我要给你的最后两个秘诀。当然，还有我们的额外秘诀，我们将在广告之后马上回来。《2%》。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代社会中，如何培养坚韧的意志力、好体魄以及韧性。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌失措的许多问题，都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。
That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush
即“2%”。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方搜索即可。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什到底
got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, yeah.
跟小金有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《The Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊当年的可卡因，但是，对，对，对。
But just so you know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
但为了让你知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
是的。对我和美国历史上的黑人来说，这是最重要的年份之一。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的心理健康领域经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的纯粹地去做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct?
加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，让我们就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年前单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于父子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中前后矛盾的地方。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Naranini. My mind was blown.
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税金被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·纳拉尼尼。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I'm going to teach you how to hack your brain and your motivational systems using some of the
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里icopa县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。所以我要教你如何利用神经科学的一些最基本原理来破解你的大脑和动力系统，这些原理创造了一些最非基本的行为改变和习惯，我知道这些对于培养自律至关重要。这就是这门科学的奇妙之处。它是如此简单，但又如此有效。因此，在培养自律方面，我们需要最清醒认识的神经递质是多巴胺。多巴胺通常被认为是我们的快乐化学物质，对吧？当你吃到美味的食物、喝咖啡因、体验到快乐的事情时，你就会得到它。但它远不止于此。它不仅仅关乎快乐、享乐主义和享受。它也是在动力控制方面最至关重要的神经递质，因为它在
most basic principles of neuroscience that create some of the most non-basic behavioral changes and habits that I know for building your self-discipline. This is the thing about this science. It is so simple, but it is so effective. So when it comes to building self-discipline, the neurotransmitter we need to be most conscious of is dopamine. Dopamine is, often thought of as our happy chemical, right? It's the thing that you get when you have a tasty meal, when you drink caffeine, when you experience something pleasurable. But it's also so much more than that. It's not just about pleasure and hedonism and enjoyment. It is also the neurotransmitter that is most crucial when it comes to motivational control because of the role that it plays in
奖励导向学习和自律中发挥着作用。当我们完成一个目标、一项任务时。当我们完成一项任务时，我们喜欢它，我们就会迎来一剂多巴胺的分泌。当我们实现一个目标时，我们同样会得到多巴胺。这将驱使我们继续朝着更大的宏大目标努力，继续执行那些对培养成功、进步和自律至关重要的日常和周常行动。我们可以利用其背后的科学原理来保持我们的坚持。因此，阻止我们拥有自控力或自律的最大因素，就是屈服于眼前的诱惑和心血来潮。当然，当你的待办事项列表排得满满的时候，留在床上放松一下在当下感觉会好得多。
reward guided learning and self-discipline. When we do a target, a task. When we do a task, that we like, we get a spike of dopamine. When we achieve a goal, again, we get dopamine. That is going to drive us to keep working towards our larger ambition, to keep performing those daily and weekly actions that are necessary for cultivating success, progress and self-discipline. And we can exploit the science behind that to keep us consistent. So the biggest thing that stops us from having self-control or being disciplined is buying into immediate temptation and our whims. Of course, it is going to feel so much better in the moment to stay in bed and relax when you should really be doing your like big to-do list.
当然，把学习拖延下去转而刷社交媒体，在短暂的当下感觉会更好，因为那些替代活动能给我们带来快乐。然而，我们在那些时刻遇到的是我们所说的即时满足。而这种即时满足实际上只是一针快速的多巴胺注射，随着时间的推移，它会降低我们的多巴胺基线，并产生我们所知的快乐下调。当某种神经递质（在本例中为多巴胺）在大脑中的受体数量由于该神经递质水平的提高而减少时，就会发生这种情况，这意味着我们需要更少的冲击点、更少的连接点来真正获得相同数量的
Of course, it's going to feel momentarily better to procrastinate studying in favor of scrolling through social media because those alternative activities give us pleasure. However, what we're encountering in those moments is what we call instant gratification. And that instant gratification is actually just a quick dopamine shot that over time lowers our dopamine baseline and it creates what we know as the down regulation of pleasure. So this occurs when the number of receptors in our brain for a neurotransmitter, in this case dopamine are decreased because of an increase in that neurotransmitters levels, meaning that we need less points of impact, less points of connection to actually have access to that same amount of
快乐，因为有太多的这种化学物质充斥着我们的大脑。这就是屈服于即时满足的负面影响。快乐实际上变得不那么快乐了，因为快乐太多了，但它的质量不如我们从长期目标中获得的快乐和满足感。但因为我们拥有的受体变少了，这也意味着多巴胺在让我们保持专注和保持在正轨上的作用变得不那么强大了。所以对此的替代方法是，推迟即时满足，以换取来自自律的长期回报，显而易见。这包括安排你什么时候给自己这些微小的多巴胺冲击。例如，只允许自己一周睡懒觉一次，而不是每天都这样，这样它才会显得更特别，或者给自己一个
pleasure because we have so much of this chemical flooding our brain. So this is the downside of buying into instant gratification. Pleasure actually becomes less pleasant because there is so much of it, but it's not at the same quality as the pleasure and the satisfaction, we would get from a long-term goal. But because we have fewer receptors, it also means that that dopamine becomes less powerful in keeping us focused and staying on track. So the alternative to this is to hold off on instant gratification for a long-term reward that comes from self-discipline, obviously. This involves scheduling when you're going to give yourself those small spikes. For example, only letting yourself sleep in once a week rather than every day so that it becomes more special, or giving yourself a
快乐感会减弱，因为有大量这种化学物质充斥着我们的大脑。所以，这就是沉迷于即时满足的弊端。由于快乐太多，它实际上变得不那么快乐了，而且其质量远不及我们从长期目标中获得的快乐和满足感。但由于我们的受体减少，这也意味着多巴胺在保持我们集中注意力和步入正轨方面的作用也减弱了。因此，与之对立的选择显然是克制即时满足，以换取来自自律的长期回报。这包括规划好什么时候给自己这些微小的刺激。例如，每周只允许自己睡一次懒觉，而不是每天都睡，这样它就会变得更特别，或者给自己一个
break to scroll on your phone whilst you're studying once every two hours rather than once every 30 minutes, because this increases our dopamine baseline. You are delaying gratification for a better feeling later on. So by managing your dopamine in this way, you experience more fulfillment because you're not desensitizing yourself to all this pleasure. Another way to utilize our dopamine systems to become more self-disciplined is to create a reward schedule for yourself when it comes to your long-term goals. If you set out to get straight A's or HDs in every course that you're taking this semester, it is going to take a while before you get to experience the rewards for your efforts. Instead, what you need to do is create a schedule of positive
学习时每两个小时在手机上刷一会儿，而不是每30分钟刷一次，因为这能提高我们的多巴胺基线。你是在推迟即时满足，以便稍后获得更好的感觉。因此，通过这种方式管理多巴胺，你会体验到更多的成就感，因为你没有让自己对所有这些快乐变得麻木。利用我们的多巴胺系统来变得更加自律的另一种方法是，在设定长期目标时，为自己制定一个奖励日程表。如果你打算在这个学期的每一门课程中都拿全A或HD，那么在你的努力得到回报之前，需要一段时间。相反，你需要做的是制定一个积极的
reinforcement for yourself that is aligned directly to your efforts and the small achievements that you're going to come across in pursuit of your goal. So I'm going to keep using this academic example because I think it is such a great way of demonstrating this. If your end goal is to get a 4.0 by the end of the semester, break this into smaller goals. To get that HD, you also need to get an A in your mid-sem and you also need to get an A on your essay. Don't let those small accomplishments go unnoticed or unrewarded. Give yourself a little treat. Let yourself have some dopamine in response. Take yourself out for dinner. Buy yourself something really nice. Give yourself the day off. Managing our dopamine systems doesn't mean completely denying ourselves any dopamine that isn't
强化日程表，直接与你的努力以及你在追求目标过程中遇到的小成就相契合。所以我将继续使用这个学术例子，因为我认为这是展示这一点的绝佳方式。如果你的最终目标是在学期末拿到4.0的绩点，那就把它分解成更小的目标。为了拿到HD，你还需要在期中考试中拿A，论文也需要拿A。不要让这些小成就默默无闻或没有奖励。给自己一点小犒劳。让自己分泌一些多巴胺作为回应。带自己去吃大餐。给自己买件真正喜欢的东西。给自己放一天假。管理我们的多巴胺系统并不意味着完全剥夺自己任何与
associated with our long-term goal, right? It's about just making yourself or achieving a greater balance so that when you want to use your dopamine, I know that sounds quite strange, but like, when you, yeah, when you want to use your dopamine for the reasons that are important to you, you actually have access to it, rather than feeling like there's this whole chemical process going on in your brain that means that you can't actually set goals and meet them. So this thing that we're talking about, this reward schedule, there are a few caveats. The important thing is that we want to use a continuous reinforcement schedule whereby every time we perform the target behavior or achieve the target outcome. In this instance, achieving a grade that contributes to a good overall GPA, you need to be rewarded for that.
长期目标无关的多巴胺，对吧？它只是关乎让自己达到或实现更大的平衡，这样当你想要使用多巴胺时——我知道这听起来有点奇怪——但就像当你、是的，当你想为了对你重要的原因使用多巴胺时，你实际上能够触及它，而不是觉得大脑中正在进行着一整套化学过程，导致你无法真正设定目标并实现它们。所以我们讨论的这个奖励日程表，有一些注意事项。最重要的一点是，我们希望使用连续强化日程表，即每次我们执行目标行为或达成目标结果时。在这个例子中，达成有助于获得良好整体GPA的分数，你就需要为此受到奖励。
So it therefore encourages us to keep doing those things. the thing is you might experience like some boredom and displeasure during the transition but soon your quality of life actually increases and it's shown that we do have stronger self-control we are happier we do experience fewer negative emotions and you actually appreciate pleasure even more i think doing hard things being self-disciplined is a shift from instant gratification but you'll find that when you delay reward your satisfaction actually increases, you're going to enjoy it more, you feel good about yourself, rather than in those moments where you just live your life based on short-term pleasure and hedonism and giving
因此，这会鼓励我们继续做这些事情。问题是，在过渡期间你可能会经历一些无聊和不快，但很快你的生活质量实际上会提高，并且研究表明，我们的自控力的确更强了，我们更快乐了，我们经历的负面情绪更少了，而且你实际上会更加感激快乐。我认为做困难的事情、保持自律是从即时满足的一种转变，但你会发现，当你延迟奖励时，你的满足感实际上会增加，你会更享受它，你会对自己感觉良好，而不是在那些只靠短期快乐、享乐主义以及满足自己一切欲望来生活的时刻。
yourself anything that you want. You know, if you were, you know, I always think about this in the sense of like being the parent to your inner child, you wouldn't let yourself like run around and eat sugar whenever you wanted it. You wouldn't let yourself stay up till 4 a.m. if you were like a 12, if you were like a six-year-old child. So why are you letting your adult self do things that you know are self-sabotaging your efforts for a bigger goal? That is the main premise of using this reward scheduling. You want to be in control of how you behave. And when you want to stay motivated, when you want to be focused,
你知道，如果你是，你知道，我总是从成为内心的孩子的父母的角度来思考这个问题：你不会让自己随心所欲地到处跑去吃糖。如果你是个12岁，或者说是个6岁的小孩子，你不会让自己熬夜到凌晨4点。那么，为什么你要让成年的自己去做那些明知会自我破坏、妨碍你实现更大目标的事情呢？这就是使用这个奖励日程表的主要前提。你希望掌控自己的行为。当你想保持动力、想要保持专注时，
you want to make sure that you have the resources and the passion and the energy available to you to do that. Our fifth tip for today is possibly my favorite. That's why I saved it for last, obviously, because I really never hear people talking about this and it's one of the most fascinating areas of motivational and learning psychology. It is the principle of learned helplessness versus learned industriousness and how shifting from one to the other can actually get us to enjoy doing difficult things, which sounds great, right? Wouldn't it be great if you enjoyed the hard things on your do list. Let me explain this a little bit further. So learned helplessness occurs when we feel like no matter what we do, we cannot escape bad outcomes or failures and so we just give up. Researchers,
你要确保自己拥有实现这一目标所需的资源、热情和精力。今天的第五个建议可能是我最喜欢的。这就是为什么我显然把它留到最后，因为我真的从未听人谈论过这一点，它是动机和学习心理学中最迷人的领域之一。这就是习得性无助与习得性勤奋的原则，以及从一种状态转变为另一种状态如何能真正让我们开始享受做困难的事情听起来很棒，对吧？如果能享受待办事项清单上的难事，那不是很好吗？让我进一步解释这一点。习得性无助发生在无论我们做什么都觉得无法逃避不好的结果或失败，于是我们选择放弃的时候。研究人员，
when they first discovered this, began to observe it in animals whereby they would keep them restrained and then expose them to some really negative, aversive condition like pain or an unpleasant noise. These animals couldn't escape as sad as it. You know, it's pretty sad what they used to do back then, but what it showed was that even when they let the animals out, even when they removed the leash or the collar, they still kept enduring the painful situation, even though now they could get away from it. They had learned that they were helpless in changing their situation. And although a lot of the synestrial research was conducted on animals, we can see that in human behavior as well. No matter what you do, maybe you found that you just
当他们最初发现这一点时，开始在动物身上观察到这种现象：他们将动物限制起来，然后让它们承受一些非常消极、厌恶的条件，比如疼痛或令人不快的声音。这些动物无法逃跑，这很令人难过。你知道，他们过去做的事情挺残忍的，但它表明，即使后来把动物放出来了，即使解开了皮带或项圈，它们仍然继续忍受痛苦的处境，尽管现在它们本可以逃离。它们已经学会了自己在改变现状方面是无助的。尽管许多早期的研究都是在动物身上进行的，但我们也能在人类行为中看到这一点。无论你做什么，也许你发现自己就是
can't stick to a diet. You can't stay focused on your work. You can't get the outcome you want, the growth you want, the numbers you want. Because you are not seeing that correlation between action and reward, you lose faith in your self-discipline, in your actions, and you quit. So what is the alternative in those situations? Well, it's about shifting from a learned helplessness mindset to a learned industriousness mindset. The difference here is that learned industriousness focuses on the pleasure in the action itself. We aren't just reliant on what we gain from the outcome, but just like the genuine sensation and good feelings that just come with working hard. I think this is so, so important to have an equal investment in your goal, but also feel like you're getting something out of the
无法坚持节食。你无法专注于工作。你无法得到想要的结果、想要的发展、想要的数据。因为你没有看到行动与奖励之间的这种关联，你对自己的自律和行动失去了信心，然后你放弃了。那么在这些情况下，有什么替代方案呢？好吧，那就是从习得性无助的心态转变为习得性勤奋的心态。这里的区别在于，习得性勤奋关注的是行动本身的乐趣。我们不仅依赖从结果中获得的东西，还依赖努力工作本身带来的真切感受和美好感觉。我认为这一点非常非常重要，既要对目标有同等的投入，也要觉得你从这个
journey, that it's not just a slug, that there's nothing enjoyable about it. And I also think that you can feel excited by how much you can push yourself. You can romanticize the difficult times, the long nights, the exhausting runs, the hours of studying, instead of just romanticizing this future outcome that you're hoping for. And it has a lot of benefits for self-discipline, individuals who have high levels of industriousness, they have a lot of history of applying greater efforts towards tasks. It's been demonstrated that they have more task persistence. They're less likely to quit when things get difficult because that difficulty is actually, I don't want to say enjoyable, but it's fulfilling. So how can we train ourselves to do this? How do we make
旅程中有所收获，它不仅仅是一场苦差事，其中并非毫无乐趣。而且我认为你也可以为自己能突破多少极限而感到兴奋。你可以把艰难的时光、漫长的夜晚、筋疲力尽的跑步、数小时的学习进行浪漫化，而不是仅仅去浪漫化你所期盼的未来结果。这对自律有很多好处，那些勤奋程度高的人，他们在任务上投入更多努力的历史很长。事实证明，他们更具任务持久性。当事情变得困难时，他们更不容易放弃，因为这种困难实际上——我不想说是有趣的，但它是充实的。那么我们如何训练自己做到这一点呢？我们如何做出
that shift? What we need to do is begin to reward our actions, not just our outcomes, through paired reinforcement. So the gummy bear method is an excellent example of this. If you have 20 pages you need to read for a class, after every page you give yourself a gummy bear, or something that you like, making it so that you begin to associate hard work with something pleasant. We can also do this by romanticizing our labor.
这种转变？我们需要做的是，通过配对强化，开始奖励我们的行动，而不仅仅是结果。小熊软糖法就是这方面的一个极佳例子。如果你有20页课本需要阅读，每读完一页，你就给自己一颗小熊软糖，或者你喜欢的东西，这样你就会开始把辛苦工作与愉快的事情联系起来。我们也可以通过对劳动进行浪漫化来做到这一点。
Instead of thinking, oh my God, I'm so exhausted, I don't want to work this hard. It would be so much easier to quit. switch that attitude by deliberately creating thoughts like, it's actually really exciting to see how far I can go. I think I'm going to look back on these moments with a lot of fondness and pride. I'm so proud of myself for how I keep going. It is thrilling and stimulating to be doing these things that are difficult to push myself. We are reinforcing the feeling of high effort. As we get better at this, the self-discipline that is contained in that becomes a valued part of our
与其脑海中想着：“天哪，我太累了，我不想这么努力工作。放弃会容易得多。”不如通过刻意产生诸如“看看自己能走多远，其实真的挺让人兴奋的。我想我以后回想起这些时刻时，会满心温柔与骄傲。我为自己能坚持下去感到无比自豪。做这些困难的事情、突破自己，是惊险刺激且振奋人心的”之类的心态，来扭转这种态度。我们在强化高强度的努力感。当我们在这方面变得更好时，其中蕴含的自律就会成为我们
identity, whereby we begin to see ourselves as a hard worker, as someone with self-control, as someone who is tenacious and passionate and kind of willing to do things that others can't. And in this way, you've shifted your goal from not just being internally motivated, but something that informs who you are and who you want to become, which is even more encouraging. Now, I want to give you one final piece of advice when it comes to self-discipline to finish off. and it may seem very contrary to the other things that we've talked about, but I think it's equally important. You need to let yourself fail sometimes, make mistakes, have slip-ups, and still
身份认同中受珍视的一部分，从而让我们开始将自己视为一个努力工作的人、一个有自控力的人、一个坚韧且充满热情、愿意做他人做不到的事情的人。通过这种方式，你的目标已经超越了仅仅获得内在激励，而是变成了一种塑造你是谁以及你想成为谁的因素，这就更加鼓舞人心了。现在，在结束之际，我想给出关于自律的最后一条建议。这可能看起来与我们之前谈论的其他事情截然相反，但我认为它同样重要。你有时需要让自己失败，犯错误，经历挫折，并且依然
show yourself as much self-compassion and love as you would if you were perfect at all times. You just can't hate yourself into self-discipline. I'm going to say that again, you can't hate yourself. and you can't hate yourself into self-discipline because self-discipline comes from a place of care and investment in yourself. Time and time again, we see research that shows that when you use shame as a motivator, self-blame, self-hatred as a motivator, all that discipline becomes so much harder to keep up because you're doing it from a place of loathing and negativity. You can make mistakes.
向自己展现出如同你在任何时候都表现得完美时一样多的自我同情与爱。你无法通过厌恶自己来获得自律。我要再说一遍，你无法厌恶自己，你无法通过厌恶自己来获得自律，因为自律源于对自己的关爱和投入。一次又一次的研究表明，当你将羞耻感作为动力、将自责和自我厌恶作为动力时，所有这些纪律都会变得更加难以保持，因为你这样做是出于厌恶和消极情绪。你可以犯错。
In fact, I think that it's really useful to refafer. and grow. You can start something new and just not be the best at it. Not every day needs to be insanely productive. That's actually not sustainable. But what you do need to do is just show up. Just be consistent. Even if you're not being perfect, even if you're only at the gym for 10 minutes, you still wet and you still are repeating a pattern of behaviors that is going to become routine. You know, I think that if you're still listening right now, if you've made it this far, you're obviously super committed to yourself. You're obviously super committed to your goals. You're already miles ahead of everyone else who has already convinced themselves that even the first step in
事实上，我认为重新调整和成长真的很有用。你可以开始做一件新事，却并非做到最好。并非每一天都需要疯狂地产出。这其实是不可持续的。但你真正需要做的是出勤。要保持连贯。即使你没有做到完美，即使你在健身房只呆了10分钟，你依然流汗了，你依然在重复一种将成为常规的行为模式。你知道，我认为如果你现在还在听，如果你坚持到了这一步，你显然对自我超级投入。你显然对自己的目标超级投入。你已经把那些甚至连自律的第一步都嫌太难而说服自己放弃的人远远甩在了身后。
self-discipline is too hard. And now I guess you also have the tools that you need. You know what needs to be done. And to be completely honest, I'm just super proud of you for even caring enough about yourself and your future to be considering this change in your life. Whatever that may be. I think that self-discipline is the secret ingredient. It is the master key to everything that you want in life. So I really hope that you have enjoyed this episode. I hope that you can apply this to your life, that you have learned something. If there's someone else in your life who you think might enjoy this, who you think might take something from this content, from the science that we've shared, please feel free to forward it onto them. Make sure that you are following and leave a five-star
现在我想你也有了所需的工具。你知道该做些什么。老实说，仅仅因为你足够关爱自己和未来，从而考虑在生活中做出这种改变，我就为你感到无比骄傲。无论那改变是什么。我认为自律是秘密的配料。它是你想要的生活中一切事物的总钥匙。所以我真的希望你喜欢这一集。我希望你能将这些应用到生活中，并且有所收获。如果你身边有其他人也可能会喜欢这个，或者你认为他们能从这些内容以及我们分享的科学知识中有所收获，请随时转发给他们。确保关注并留下五星
review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening to this right now. Of course, if there's an episode suggestion, I say this at the end of every episode, please send it to me. You never know, I never know who else might relate to some of the things that are on your mind and I take a lot of inspiration from what you guys are going through this episode in itself. You guys voted on this one. So if there's anything that is in your thoughts that you feel other people could benefit from please send it my way at that psychology podcast or at jemisbeg we will be back next week with a special guest episode on tuesday so see you then 2% that's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available i'm michael easter am on my podcast 2% i break down the science of mental toughness fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world
评价，无论你是在苹果播客、Spotify还是其他什么地方收听。当然，如果你有节目建议，我在每一集结尾都会说这个，请发给我。你永远不会知道，我也永远不知道还有谁会与你脑海中的某些想法产生共鸣，而且我从你们正在经历的事情中获得了许多灵感，这一集本身就是你们投票决定的。所以，如果有任何你们觉得其他人能从中受益的想法，请通过That Psychology Podcast或@jemisbeg发送给我。我们下周二将带着一集特别嘉宾节目回归，到时见。2%，这就是当旁边还有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在怪异的现代世界中培养精神坚韧、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
让自己经历一些苦难，你就会从另一端蜕变成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的。收听《2%》。名字就是数字2加上百分号。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回顾过去》（Look Back At It）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克兰·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。那是个疯狂的年代。那是个疯狂的年代。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host's Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难成长》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都实在不安全去进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人穿着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去这样做。在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吧？我把测试动了一次手脚。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困之爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困之爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。